The Last of Us HBO's new zombie drama is
based on the unforgettable game but how
do the characters stack up between the
show and the source material
fans of the video game are bound to have
a closer relationship with Joe Miller
than any other character in the series
not only is he the protagonist of the
story but he is also the character
controlled by the player for the
majority of the game Pedro Pascal plays
Joel in the television series while the
character was voiced by Troy Baker in
the game pass guard has proven himself
more than capable of helming a
television series for starring roles in
the Mandalorian and narcos the only
notable cosmetic change in Joel is an
ethnic shift away from the game's
Caucasian iteration of Joel to suit
Pascal's Chilean Heritage this switch is
unlikely to have any effect on the
narrative and falls in line with Neil's
drug min's commendable focus on
increasing diversity whenever possible
which was reflected in The Last of Us
Part 2 when speaking with GQ druckman
said that he considers a diverse cast of
characters to be as important as any
other storytelling or gameplay
components based on everything we've
seen thus far Pascal seems to have
nailed Joel's Gruff nature and rugged
mannerisms and judging from its own face
your hair down to the broken watch that
serves as a reminder of his daughter
Sarah's death he looks the part I'm not
family no
cargo
alongside Joel Ellie Williams as the
other main character and the only other
person that players control for portions
of the game aside from Sarah for a brief
time in the prologue Ellie is played by
Bella Ramsay in the HBO show while she
was voiced by Ashley Johnson in the
games Ramsay is still early on in her
career and is best known for her
portrayal of Leona Mormont on HBO's Game
of Thrones which provided her with her
very first role she has had a few
notable roles since such as a recurring
character on his dark materials but the
last of us has set to become her biggest
starring role to date although Ramsay is
19 years old which is five years older
than Ellie is in the game she has a
youthful enough appearance surpassed for
a 14 year old and more or less matches
the look and height of the video game
character Ramsay looks the part right
down to the eyebrow scar but the one
noteworthy visual change from the game
is Ramsey's brunette hair color Ali's
hair in the game is Auburn the character
is also referred to in dialogue as a
redhead in the game Ellie's hair color
had already been a point of confusion
amongst fans of the game and the TV
series will likely exacerbate that
debate
set is an important character early on
in the story of the last of us though
she does not continue with Ellie and
Joel on their cross-country Adventure
she has both a close personal and
professional relationship with Joel and
she is the one who convinces him to
transport Ali to Salt Lake City from
Boston to get to the fireflies in the TV
series Tess is played by anatov who is
best known for her roles on the show's
mind Hunter and Fringe tour was no
stranger to video games having earlier
provided the voice of the main character
in Heavenly sword visually 12 seems to
capture Tess's toughness and to make up
matches Tessa's injuries quite well in
the show cesus has seems considerably
longer and she's lacking the trademark
black and white bandana that holds her
hair up in the game the red shirt worn
by Tess and the game seems to be present
but it's covered by an outer layer
overall it doesn't seem like the show's
version of Tess will be a major
departure from her depiction in the game
in the game bill is a memorable side
character voiced by W Earl Brown who
only appears in the Lincoln chapter
casting a household name like Nick
Offerman in the role and including him
in four episodes instead of just one
suggests that the series will expand on
this portion of the original story a
casting of Murray Barlett as Frank in
four episodes furthers his implication
in the game Frank is dead by the time
players find him but his backstory
subtly reveals him to be Bill's former
romantic partner Offerman seems like the
perfect casting for Bill the video game
version of Bill is a bit more out of
shape and generally and camps on the TV
version appears to be but offer money
said a decent fit for Bill's physicality
and a great match for its personality
and demeanor cosmetically offerman's
beard is darker and a bit Fuller than
video game bills and his hair is a bit
tidier but the style isn't far off
modeling is a key figure amongst the
fireflies a paramilitary resistance
group with questionable morals in the
game she has present in Boston and after
being wounded leaves Ellie in the care
of Joel and Tess she later re-emerges
near the end of the story when the
protagonist finally reached the Firefly
base in Salt Lake City in both the video
game and the HBO series Marlene is
played by Merle Dandridge while there
are a handful of voice actors from the
game contributing live-action
performances in the TV series dandrich
is the only actor to play the same
character across both mediums the
casting couldn't possibly get any more
authentic than this her voice is
guaranteed to be 100 accurate to the
game and although the game's character
design wasn't explicitly modeled after
her she also looks to pass her wardrobe
and hair seemed to be a perfect match
for the character model as well
inclusion of Riley makes it clear that
the HBO series isn't just adapting the
base version of The Last of Us it's
tackling the Left Behind DLC as well
Riley is mentioned through dialogue in
the game but doesn't appear until the
prequel DLC Ellie and Riley are close
friends and begin to form a romance
until disaster strikes I haven't seen
you
and I don't even know how long
45 days
they are both bitten by the infected at
the same time leading to Riley's death
and the discovery that Ellie is immune
to the cordyceps infection in Left
Behind Riley was voiced by Yani King
monshine who was in her 40s in real life
since the character is meant to be 16 in
the game a younger actor was needed for
the live-action adaptation storm Reed
who's the same age as co-star beta
Ramsey takes over as Riley in the show
in terms of costuming the TV version of
Riley has added a head wrapping to hold
her head back that wasn't present in the
game she also wears her hair in a long
ponytail whereas the game character
keeps the hair in a tight burn a
wardrobe has longer sleeves than the
game equivalent but otherwise lines up
well even down to the beaded bracelet on
her wrist
Tommy Miller is Joel's brother and is a
major character in both the last of us
and The Last of Us Part 2. just like
Joel Tommy is Caucasian in the video
game but he's got another ethnicity in
the TV show and a spirit of diversity
and to line up with leading man Pedro
Pascal in the show Tommy is played by
Gabrielle Luna who's of Mexican descent
in the video game The Brothers don't
reunite until far into Joel and Ellie's
cross-country Journey Tommy is slated to
appear in all 10 episodes in the first
season it's clear that Tommy will be a
substantially larger character in the
show than he was in the first game
visually Tommy looks quite different
between the mediums Luna Sports a
different hair color and style he has
clean shaven as opposed to sporting a
full beard as he does in the game also
he is free from the scars and blemishes
present on his digital counterparts
though that might change as a series
progresses his wardrobe is a direct
match for the Tommy of the game with a
fluffy colored jean jacket and it can be
seen using a sniper rifle which is
revealed to be a specialty of Tommy's in
The Last of Us Part 2.
Sarah Miller is Joel's daughter who
meets a heartbreaking end in the opening
moments of the game as she apparently
appears in two episodes of the series it
is safe to say that her role has been
expanded from the game possibly in the
form of flashbacks just like the actors
playing her father and Uncle the actor
playing the TV version of Sarah is
significantly less Caucasian than the
video game version of Sarah the role of
Sarah in the TV series is played by Nico
Parker who is a daughter of actor
tanduay Newton and Des of Zimbabwe
descent no mention of Sarah's mother has
ever made in the games but the TV series
could change this after all the show is
already confirmed to include Ellie's
Mother Anna who was also absent from the
games at 18 years old Parker looks a
fair bit older than the video game
version of Sarah it was supposed to be
12. Sarah's t-shirt and the show is a
different color but seems to be for the
same fictional banders in the game
Anakin drops eagle-eyed fans noticed at
the back of Sarah's shirt foreshadows
almost all of the locations visited in
the game it remains to be seen whether
or not the TV version keeps the subtle
Easter egg intact
Henry is a brief but vital character and
the luck could hinge on the right or
wrong casting Lamar Johnson is
portraying the live-action version of
Henry while Brandon Scott's lent his
voice to the character in the video game
Scott bears are somewhat closer
resemblance to the character than
Johnson which likely comes from our
Naughty Dog captured full body
performances when making the game for
motion capture and artistic reference
might not be her father
Lamar Johnson has been part of a few big
film and TV projects like the hates you
give and your honor but he is likely
best known for his abilities as a dancer
as displayed on the TV show The Next
Step the similarities between dancing
and fight choreography should give
Johnson a leg up when it comes to action
sequences Henry wears multiple layers
and an Overcoat in the TV series but he
only ever wears a light tank top in the
game this change makes sense for the
practicality of it and his underlayer
looks to be a match for his tank top
from the game which is a nice touch
Samus Henry's kid brother on the subject
of one of the game's most heartbreaking
moments fans of the game will know to
prepare themselves for the heavy
emotions that are sure to follow when
the TV show reaches salmon Henry's
subplot Simon has played in the show by
Kevin Woodard and was voiced by Naji
Jita in the game at just nine years old
Woodard is still at the start of his
acting career with the last of us the
dynamic between aliens summons the
potential to be a bit awkward on screen
if it closely follows the game since the
characters are only separated by one
year's age difference but Ramsay is just
about a full decade older than Woodard
Woodard is death in real life which is
not a trade shared in the video game but
will surely factor into his TV scenes
between this and his younger age some
might be quite different in the show but
these differences might make him an even
more compelling character
Robert is a minor antagonist from the
opening Boston section of the game he is
a gun Runner who double crosses Jordan
Tess and leads to the game's first
action sequences though his appearance
is limited his role is vital that he
inadverts on these serves as a catalyst
for Joel and Tess coming into contact
with the fireflies which leads to
Marlene entrusting them to transport
Ellie the Robert character was played by
veteran voice actor Robin Atkin Downs on
the video game while Brendan Fletcher
has been brought in to play the
live-action version not much has been
revealed about Fletcher's appearance as
Robert in the TV series as of yet but
Fletcher is more than capable of
portraying the role
[Music]
foreign
[Music]